all right hello everyone how are you
guys all doing hope you guys are having
a wonderful day this is the beginning of
noob with the mill episode 8 if you guys
don't know the gist of the series I
started off with a mill a little while
ago and now I have more than a m we're
starting this uh episode with about a 70
mil bank and uh really nothing to spend
our money on right now so we actually
might get a decent amount this episode
I'd imagine uh we're going to start off
this episode by hating our lives a
little bit at least I'm going to hate my
life and we're going to go ahead and do
one small favor so let's get right on
into that but first I remembered I have
to do Shiloh Village so two quests all
right here we go we're going to go ahead
and finish up Shiloh Village so actually
a pretty big Quest um eventually
whenever I unlock whatever it is to
actually get tasks from Durell it may be
worth it because he assigns a lot more
boss tasks which would be really fun for
us to do but that's two Quest points a
little bit of crafting XP and more
importantly the ability to start one
small favor this was like a half an hour
Quest so I mean realistically one small
favor is only twice as much and it's not
even that bad just a lot of running and
there we are first a little bit of postc
com but went ahead and did some crafting
in hopes to event get some Slayer Rings
which I'll do this episode but uh from
there went ahead and got a hellhounds
task so there's that all right pretty
strange way that we're going to go ahead
and get a farming level but there it is
I'll be getting a couple more on this so
I'm just going to go through them real
quick all right so here we go going to
go ahead and finish up one small favor
so took damn near an hour but I think
we're finally done going to go ahead and
use the XP lamps on mining I think
because I think you need 50 to be able
to use them on something and that is
probably the most annoying skill that I
can think to use it on so let's see what
we can do
uh ideally I'd like to use it on
something else but I don't think that
there's anything we can really put it on
agility maybe if it allows for it oh
yeah I definitely put it on agility then
so I think that probably got us to level
yeah 45 there and then we'll get 46
haven't even been to the canonist course
yet and we're at 47 agility so that's
really nice all right there we go so
King's Ransom Quest is done don't
believe we get any levels off of that
but I am going to use this on agility
again okay get on but we're going to go
ahead and get P now and there we go that
is the end of the uh whatever the fight
waves whatever this is so now we can use
Pi which is pretty cool so I'm going to
go ahead make a different video but p is
a huge thing with this account and uh
yeah probably going to do some more
quests today just because I'm you know
I've only done a couple quests this
weekend really want to get it going but
I did knock off a terrible one in one
small favor and so after we got done
with the fight waves I ended up doing my
declaw video If you guys saw that but
that's an entirely different thing had a
lot of fun with that um if you guys saw
it and I hope you guys enjoyed it as as
well or as much as I did I guess but
doing this in post so I kind of have a
big block here of just random stuff that
I'm throwing together I like to include
just like a lot of stuff so that you
guys can see where my account's going
like obviously I'm just including like
short clips of everything that I'm doing
as you guys can see at this time I'm
primarily working on farming as it's a
skill that I don't ever want to get in a
position where I'm like oh I need to get
my farming up 10 levels and then it's
like well now I got to do that and it
just it delays what I can do in gamees
so I figure right now it's just as good
of a time as I need to go ahead and do
that speaking of things that go ahead
and delay me in game another one is
Slayer Rings not having those is very
just painful as I have to teleport to
verac then run and it's just something
that I don't want to be a part of so I
went ahead and got a ton of crafting
levels as you guys can see so I end up
getting 75 in the end but you guys are
seeing some of the earlier levels Slayer
rings are definitely something I would
recommend for your average player like
it's something like it's one of the I
think it was the first skill that I got
to 75 like while crafting may seem to be
expensive the time you'll save is by far
worth it and eventually you're going to
have to get all of your levels up
anyways in the end like in end game like
you want to progress to the point where
you have high levels so you may as well
go ahead and do that as you guys can see
there hit my 100th Tas that was pretty
cool um from there go ahead and get turo
I don't end up showing in this clip but
I do end up canceling them and then get
black team and so I don't know why that
cut out all weird but it's my own fault
I guess um end up training a little bit
of range the problem with range is
there's not much of an applicability of
it I had to you know sound out that word
but you can't really apply it in a whole
lot of skills unless you have a blowpipe
and even with the blowpipe the main ones
I'd want to do would also be prayer like
using prayer like in pet catacombs and
stuff like that and to use prayer and
the blowpipe at the same time I just
really can't justify that with the
amount of money I have and the fact that
this is kind of a money-making series
also like I'm trying to build up a bank
so to go ahead and do that before before
I even have a decent bank would be
pretty annoying I would imagine to most
people as I'd constantly just be
knocking myself back down to between 20
and 40 mil so that's something I try to
stay away from um if you guys noticed
that there's a lot of post in this
episode like postom I mean this is a
huge block of it right here but the
reason for that is that I currently
reside at college so I have a roommate
and lately he's been listening to or I
guess watching a lot more Netflix so
there's not a whole lot I can do about
that I don't want to just interrupt him
like every 15 minutes and tell him to be
quiet and turn down his [__] for a
second while I you know make a 5-second
clip I'd imagine it be pretty annoying
so if I can go ahead and do some posts
then that's what I'm going to do so
hopefully it isn't that big of a bother
for you guys just know that in the
future it's not something I plan to do
like after the school year's over next
year I'm living off campus and we'll
have you know all just all the space in
the world no noise like it'll be great
so I'll be able to record whenever now
this was something that was pretty uh
pretty impressive so I've never really
done a fire cape on a very lowlevel like
not low level like I'm combat 100 I
think almost so it's not that low but I
did only have 80 range so I was pretty
impressed I was able to do it and have
so many supplies left honestly but uh
that was pretty nice didn't get the pet
but you know what there's uh there's
always more opportunities so from there
went ahead and got a cal fight task one
thing I'm trying to do with Slayer is
get more you know boss tasks so as you
guys can see here I go ahead and unlock
more kbds and then uh also just wyverns
for a little bit of money all right what
a great day to be alive shift drop is
finally in the game so I'm so happy
about that oh man I can finally start
doing skills that I've wanted to do like
fishing not really wanted to do but that
I've been pushing off due to this update
wood cutting with teaks was what I also
wanted to AFK and do we got Hunter like
it's going to be great now I'm so happy
if you guys don't know which I don't
know why you would cuz I haven't ever
recorded it I bought like 40 ranar seeds
and I've been trying to go and just do
constant like herb runs whenever I can
and uh here in the future we'll have a
clip of me like selling off all 40 and
I'm probably just going to constantly
invest in more seeds so like however
many herbs I get I'll sell them all off
get more seeds do that and whatnot so
going to go do a uh herb run and then
probably get back into Slayer but I may
try to celebrate the shift drop and do a
little bit of fishing just got 78 slayer
at kbd that's pretty lit but uh I only
got 12 kbds to kill which is kind of
rough um I guess black dragons but
realistically kbds um I extended black
dragons too as you guys saw in the
previous clip because I really want to
be able to kill like 40 per task just
cuz I want the pet so bad all right so
after that level went ahead and got
another task this is imp post if you
guys can't tell but uh ended up getting
some fire Giants and then from there
obviously you know knock those out more
hell hounds just a ton of catacomb stuff
but this was actually a pretty cool clip
right here the furies I was getting
about 100K margins on all of them so I
merched the margins or however many you
can buy for four hours which I think is
eight so I merched seven and ended up
making 700k so that's pretty cool went
ahead and celebrated ated the shift drop
with a little bit of uh Barbarian
fishing though so as you guys can see
right there got some levels nice to get
the lowle agility out of the way all
right so here we go going to be the
first time in a well I guess the first
time ever on this account I'm selling
off all my ranar so I have 190 which is
really nice we do have some planed right
now plus I guess the 40 some that I had
in my inventory so didn't even think
about that but going to go ahead and
sell these on so we should be able to
make a decent amount of profit here I
could see if I'd actually just make more
off of cleaning them since that seems to
be a pretty low price
and uh no it looks pretty Universal so
I'm just going to go ahead and sell
these off for about
6.7k and we'll see if they sell so there
we go that's 1.6 mil going to go ahead
and buy some RAR seeds I think initially
I had around 40 so we'll see where I can
get with this all right so we're going
to let these buy but we turned 40 almost
into 60 keep in mind that I still have
four seeds down that I haven't actually
gotten the herbs from so we turned them
into like 60 to 61 which is really nice
this is something I'm going to kind of
look to do constant and I'm just going
to build up over time the uh herb seeds
that I have in my bank so that is where
we are I got to buy more malediction
stuff I haven't done a lot of money
making this video it's really just been
grinding my account so sorry about that
but in future videos I mean once this
account is ready which it's getting
there we will definitely get on our
grind and a random farming level appears
uh should be probably getting another
one maybe on this Tas so there's that 53
and as
promised there you go and after that
farming level you know back at back at
that shift drop grind just getting up my
agility I really hate lowlevel agility
so anything I can do to just avoid that
would be nice but as you guys can see
here got another tazar task or Jad task
I guess which is great I love it man um
so I go ahead and do try to do that here
in a second I say try and you guys will
you guys will understand why but I made
about 200k off each one of these Wards
so just so you guys kind of have an idea
I still am making money on the side
while I'm not necessarily doing like
money-making methods oh [__] hate
myself every day for how [__] dumb I
am wave 61 of the fight caves and I'm
just AFK in and I drop
prey or yeah wave 60 [__] kill
me God I'm an idiot all right so uh
after hating myself for a little while
decided to go back to get another Tas we
got some blood
felds it's going to be all right oh God
I'm just so pissed got to weigh [__]
60 probably wasted like 40 [__]
minutes I'm just I just want want this
what this guy has I want so bad all
right so uh one thing I have been
meaning to do and I guess I'll go ahead
and do now is unlock the bosses tab I
don't really know if I should unlock
bosses with my current stats you know I
mean there are definitely some that I
could get that I would just not be able
to do at all but on the other side there
are some like there's a lot of bosses I
could probably do I mean they may be a
little annoying but I mean to do any
bosses at this point would just be a joy
so I'm going to unlock those now I think
we're going to go ahead and do some
Quest and start doing some clue Scrolls
though since I haven't done clue Scrolls
in a while and uh whenever I made this
account I said I kind of wanted to get
to the point to where I could actually
like do the max amount of clue Scrolls
until it's like a kind of completionist
uh sort of thing where you do like 500
easys 400 meds I think that's around the
number and right now I'm stuck on a hard
clue scroll because I need to do uh Zer
fles heater so going to go ahead and do
that now and there we go went ahead to
go do Zer flesh eaters couldn't start
the quest and realized I had to do
Chompy bird so did that it was like good
15-minute Quest but uh now on to the
actual one I wanted to do all right here
we go so going to go ahead and turn in
the ogre artifact and that should be the
end so I don't think we get any levels
maybe an herb level no nothing all right
well that is it for that Quest so we got
that done going to go ahead and finish
off our hard clue and then call at the
end of this episode and the last little
bit of post over this video so I went
ahead with the 500 eclectics and did
some medium Clues I feel like I got
relatively unlucky with how many I got
at one point I ended up going through
about to 120 eclectics without getting a
medium which is pretty unheard of but uh
definitely was a lot of fun going ahead
and doing them I look forward to doing
that in the future when I have more
money and uh you know more money at my
disposal I guess to go ahead and do more
of these but hope you guys enjoy um
there was a lot of like I mean I guess
stuff that you can only get from medium
Clues but it's just like none of it's
worth anything because you know people
just Spam medium Clues like I'm doing
right now like it's nothing uh I don't
know if you guys care about my personal
life at all but about to leave for
spring break from uh from my College go
down to Columbus and uh no clue where my
wallet is so that's quite a problem uh I
think I don't I don't I don't even know
I don't even know I wasn't in the right
state of mine last night we'll just
leave it like that and uh yeah no clue
I've uh it's 3:30 right now haven't ate
today still got to drive uh about an
hour away to go and meet one of my
friends to go to Columbus so yeah
probably not gonna eat at all I'm
starving man but yeah I mean the medium
glue grind was pretty cool I guess it it
is what it is we didn't get range boots
you guys can tell but I had a lot of fun
with it also got con levels so yeah all
right so here we go we are at the GE
just came here to show you guys what all
I have in the GE so you guys have an
idea from there so we have 1.7 mil
waiting in odium WS as we already have
one piece or two pieces of them so 1.7
mil add on to this brings us 8.1 and
then you add on this that brings us to
9.3 to 9.4 is so we're going to add on
9.3 to what the total Bank value is and
I'm going to go ahead and get that right
now and our total Bank value is 52 mil
so we add on the 9.2 mil to that we're
up to
61.2 61.3 now I know that seems like a
bit pretty big hit but also remember we
did get 75 crafting in this video we got
our prayer up last video we're working
on sets right now and as far as the
eclectics go probably won't be doing
those as much in the future they really
seem like like more so like scratch offs
I guess you could say I'm going to go
back on over to my screen now but itic
seem more like scratch offs than
anything else like you you just keep
opening them hoping that you get a
medium clue that finally gives you a r
like a Ranger boots reward personally I
do think they are the best way to go
about doing mediums but as far as the
beginning of the series I really want to
build up a bigger cash deck before I
start doing them more I was just doing
that in hopes of something big at the
very beginning and as you guys know
nothing really happened with them so
next video I'm looking forward to really
focusing on money-making and quests so
we'll get on into that here in a second
in my time but for you guys it'll
probably be a little while so if you
guys enjoyed the video make sure to
leave a like if you guys have anything
you want to tell me comment that down
below if you guys want to see these
videos as soon as I go live in the
future make sure to hit that sub button
Twitter's in the description if you want
to check that out and as always hope you
guys have a wonderful day and
[Music]
peace
me